from michael greetings michael knowles
mostly peaceful
austere religious scholar my question
concerns the bible in matthew jesus
reinforces
and specifies the rules for man to live
by he talks about divorce says any man
who marries a divorced woman is
committing adultery
can you talk about why he might have
said that or why that is the case
thanks for all you do psg elaine maxwell
did not suicide herself in the back of
the head twice
not yet not yet this is a hard saying
from christ
and so a lot of people don't want to
believe that he means what he says
he did but i think he does mean that and
there are a lot of hard sayings and
christ talks about how
there are hard sayings this is one of
the few times in the gospels
where christ explicitly gives a point of
view
on a very a
human matter on a very practical human
matter in very blunt terms
often christ is speaking in parables and
here he's being very direct
and he says man and woman they
they were made to leave their families
and join together and what god has
joined let no man separate
and uh don't don't get divorced and
he responds to people who say but the
law of moses says we can get divorced
and he says right because of the
hardness of your heart god gave you that
law but it was not so from the beginning
don't get divorced and so you shouldn't
get divorced now there there are some
questions here first of all in the case
of
certain marriages a separation
can be beneficial or even
required you know if in the case of
abuse or something endangering the kids
you might have to separate
um that's not the same as divorce
necessarily and there are implications
for how you live your life after that
kind of a separation
in some cases marriages are not valid
from the beginning this is why there is
the process of annulment
what annulment is recognizing is not
that something has gone wrong in your
marriage
later on but that something was
illegitimate about it
before the marriage actually took place
so there's that process in the church as
well
uh in in some cases people say they're
getting married but it's not
it isn't a marriage but the thing that
they are talking about is not really
a marriage in the sacramental sense and
in the sense that christ is talking
about
you know i'm speaking about this from
the perspective of you know
two thousand years of the catholic
church uh getting down very
into the specifics on this sort of thing
other
varietals of uh christian profession
have have different views on this sort
of thing i i would encourage you even if
you're not catholic
explore the catholic view on this
because there is
you know two thousand years of
literature on it to help explain what is
a
a hard saying i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you